jennifer lopez and ben affleck just went
instagram official
kinda it's a big one for me the 51 year
old singer and the 48 year old actor
made their rekindled relationship
instagram debut on thursday after j lo's
bff leah remini shared this throwback
montage
of her birthday celebration in june
don't blink
you might miss it but it's there at the
33 second mark
there they are it feels really good and
it's really nice but i'm so happy you
know what i mean we can tell
ben is seen in the middle of the shot
with his arms around jennifer
and the birthday girl jlo's hand sweetly
resting on ben's chest in the black and
white snap
but leah made no mention of the sighting
in her caption
which read in part wanted to share a
little video for my birthday with you
all
i can't thank my family and friends
enough for coming for
celebrating with me in a way that was
very special to me
i love you family i love you friends
that have become
family i love it the two have yet to
post about their newfound love on social
media
which jen is quite active on ben not so
much
and the subtle ig moment comes just
months after
the couple reunited after almost 18
years apart
a source told et earlier this month that
friends wouldn't be surprised if they
move in together
and ultimately end up together it's the
best time
it's the best time of my life although
they have not spoken
about each other publicly jlo recently
told apple music's
zane lowe that when he asked her how
she's been
no pun intended and things seemed to be
better than ever between the pair
and moving quickly as the couple was
spotted house hunting in los angeles
just last week yeah i'm ready i'm
excited about it the couple who fans
dubbed at benifer
in the early 2000s were previously
engaged
from 2002 to 2004. we were about to get
married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know
it was like a tough one for me for
whatever reason
but now benefit 2.0 is full steam ahead
e.t source adds when ben reached out to
j.lo she was really excited at the
possibility of them rekindling their
relationship
jlo has always had a love for ben now
they are in an amazing place and have
really learned what works for them as a
[Music]
couple